Japan's shrinking population...
...is forcing the country to look for new workers.
And Prime Minister Shinzo Abe thinks he's found the answer women.
Abe has outlined goals to create a "Japan in which women shine".
The name given to it: "Womenomics."
Female labor participation rate...
...rose from 46.2 percent in 2012 to 49.8 percent in 2017.
Although Abe frequently touts the success of "Womenomics",...
...a closer look highlights a work culture that systematically excludes women.
An expectation that women should stay at home...
...and be primary caregivers has held them back in workplaces all over the world,...
...but in Japan that view is particularly deep-rooted.
Japan also has the third highest gender pay gap...
...in the more developed OECD countries.
Although companies such as Toyota are appointing female executives,...
...change has been slow.
Only 4% of managerial positions are held by women in Japan...
...compared with 9% in China and 17% in the US.